crank up those subwoofers dude and check
this out
[Music]
fortnite's latest crossover sees the
dark knight return to the island but
this time it isn't a random cameo
this time is to delve into the law of
fortnite
over six issues the caped crusader and
other gothamites will arrive here
attempt to understand everything and
then hopefully get back to their own
dimension again
in this series i'll be recapping the
story and breaking down the things you
may have missed
i was planning to reenact the entire
series in fortnite
but i'm going to leave that until all
the cosmetic items are available
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamara in the store to keep
this series going and let's break down
issue one of batman fortnite zero point
hang on this guy says it better than me
batman
fortnite zero point
[Music]
our story begins in gotham city with
commissioner gordon and batman
watching a rift appear cracking the sky
above them
batman immediately knows this is a tear
in reality he's just that good
and you know why it's because i'm batman
as batman reaches the tear he sees
harley quinn in her new variant outfit
looking good harley sees batman and he's
all you landed on the wrong earth sister
and immediately starts shooting bats
away but moments before
we get a little exposition harley tells
us that
they already went through we don't get
to find out who she means
but we already know there are other dc
characters in the fortnite world
if i had to guess my money is on the
joker and poison ivy
and maybe midas rex too but it also
could mean aquaman i invited aquaman he
said
the flash and even the other batman's
hang on if it's two batmans does that
mean they're batman
are they batman's anyway my point is the
story could be contained to the few
characters in the comic book series
or maybe joker's random addition last
year is more important than we know
back to the story let's make sure we see
harley quinn smashing her knee into
bruce's face
she's no second class villain but anyway
he's okay and you know why
i have so much money i'm batman yep that
joke is in the entire video
sorry not sorry i am batman no
harley dives into the void but the dark
knight stays in gotham to run tests on
his
ipod by the looks of it all the while
being watched by a katana wielding
shadow in the background
before our hero can deduce what the heck
the crack in the sky means he is kicked
into the portal by that masked vigilante
right now we don't know who it is but we
know that there will be appearances by
the anti-hero deathstroke
and even snake eyes from gi joe is
joining the crew
whoever booted him into the rift is
doing so as part
of a bigger plan batman blacks out and
awakes on fortnite island
if you're new to comic books notice that
most things in these black rectangles
are batman's thoughts he's narrating in
his own head
and they're only verbal if we see speech
bubbles
i know you know this but i wanted to
make sure we all did
within a second of gaining consciousness
batman is already showing why he has big
brain
and immediately comes face to face with
the storm wall as the storm stops
batman deduces nothing natural moves
that way and
tells us it must be controlled
externally by someone
outside the loop literally 30 seconds
he's been here
this is why he really is the greatest
detective i think we should let him say
his name again
i'm batman a thing you may have missed
is batman's location after arriving
he came down at camp cod the very south
of the island
at this point he has no way of knowing
about the spire but we know he'll find
it soon
because it's in the trailer so i'll plot
his path
as he ventures around the island
suddenly out of nowhere batman is
ambushed by an axe-wielding maniac
don't worry though our ombre has jujitsu
skills and flips the fight
well well well how the turntables
batman attempts to reason with the
borderlands rip-off character but to no
avail
and now we understand why his internal
voice is so important
batman cannot speak upon attempting to
use sign language batman realizes
he doesn't know who he is anymore he's
just another grown man
dressed in rubber rip the dream if we
look back at thor's time in fortnite we
can see this happen to him too
upon arriving his memory slowly detached
and his ability to speak
falls silent and we all remember how
that ended
indeed batman and ruckus continue to
scrap
until batman wins and stands stoically
on top of a car
he's earned it after all he's batman i'm
batman
this spot looks to be near the old box
factory by the bunker
back a few seasons a red car sat here
looking out over the island
this would tie up into the previous shot
in which batman is about
here on the island so already his path
goes from camp cod to katy corner
this could mean this initial version of
events began over a year ago in april
2020 that's when the box factory first
arrived
of course it doesn't necessarily mean
the story is set back a year ago
but it does mean that the artwork was
created over 300 days ago
this project has been in the works for a
long time batman doesn't get time to
think he is once again pursued by the
fortnite gang after that elusive vic roy
bruce's inner monologue has him
believing he's gone mad
and is currently in arkham asylum and
quickly notes that all the combatants
are not human
what gave you that idea dude more pages
of fighting continue
but then batman recognizes one of the
fighters
[Music]
catwoman
problem is his mind is hazy and hers is
too and neither can speak to one another
instinctively batman and catwoman fight
side by side
all the while not knowing why they are
drawn to each other
their attacks are in sync maybe it's
because both of them
love to dress up as spandex animals or
maybe
they knew each other before they arrived
my boy batman gets totally smitten by
the kitten right now
and even wonders if they were lovers
dirty boy
yeah bruce and selena notice the storm
wall is nearing
yet all the other combatants continue
fighting regardless
the only option for the pair is to fight
on which they do
becoming the final two alive in the last
circle
the two embraced as the final storm
closes
lovingly looking into each other's eyes
little do they know they'll be back to
do it all over again
very soon did you notice the purple
blocks moving around during this section
well take a look at how they are
depicted in the dc trailer
look cubes hidden in plain sight kevin
the cube is part of this story
we don't actually know much at this
point as we're just at the beginning
but the trailer also tells us some other
things about batman
like how he reminds himself about
previous events
scratching notes into his armor this
happened before
and you have 22 minutes any moviegoers
out there
this technique is in many films but the
most iconic to me
is in momento a film told in reverse
order as the main protagonist has
short-term memory loss kinda like this
to keep himself up to date he tattoos
information on his body no less
if you haven't seen memento you really
should and i think it will feed into
this story
so that's what i spotted in issue 1 of
batman fortnite zero point
i would love your feedback on this video
if you wouldn't mind is the format okay
do i go too quickly would you prefer me
to stick closer to the words in the
comic books
i'm up for improvements by the end of
the series i'm hoping to remake the full
saga
inside fortnite with voices 2. i'm adam
from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure i'll leave you with
a list of legends who used my code over
the last week
thanks muchly it helps more than you
know see ya
mexican batman get out of here